ah
[ __ ]
can i help no you can't
i'll be done did you sleep all right
can't complain
and you reasonably rested i think you
had nightmares
he screamed a few times really don't
worry
i'm accustomed to that sort of thing
when mitch and scorpion came back from
the war they tossed and turned
night after night for months this went
on
whatever it is it'll pass yeah let's
hope so
come up with anything for helman i mean
as a matter of fact i did
look here
okay tell me
we're the wrench the cutter is the av
and the screwdriver is where the av
should bury its nose cone in the dust
now you must be wondering how we get the
av to do that
fellow hmg of yours my gun will be
useful elsewhere
this caliber would barely dent the armor
of a heavy hitter like that
there are other ways here the clamps are
solution
a satwaf power station
power station wait you want to use an
emp
bullseye but how we can't generate that
sort of pulse on command
would you like to bet me we drive up to
the power collection unit
break in and override the controls lift
any limiters
as soon as the av is in range we set off
the electromagnetic turbo pulse
this should smoke the av system the
drive nav systems
communications everything out like a
light
they won't stand a chance in hell
all right let's ride great hop in
it's cold out here
who owns this power station gov or corp
is there any difference who do you think
pulls the government's strings
hey i'm just wondering whose toes were
about to step all over
v look around it is simple everything
you see is owned by a corporation
you like to mess with the corpse huh
whatever gave you that idea
or wait scratch that rogue
nash the wrath thin icebee you just like
to mess with everyone
well then i suppose it's a good thing
i'm on your side isn't it
and now for something completely
different weirdest thing you've ever
transported
go what are we playing 20 questions come
on
answer the deputy finance director of
cow cause
that's chauffeuring not smuggling he
wrote in the trunk
flatlined really dead a long story
maybe someday i'll tell you
we've almost reached the dam we'll make
a quick stop here
we need to calibrate you with a turret i
want you to be able to use the gun too
and showed up our chances in general
connect here
how should i connect personal link how
else
just watch the jack sometimes you have
to jig a little bit
wired in wait a moment diagnostics first
[ __ ] it keeps giving me an error god
let me work around it and now pan am
here's johnny out in the middle of bum
[ __ ]
nowhere great work fee hey yeah
i think your implant has a virus the one
in the nape of your neck
uh i've got a bioprocessor in my head
that
operates independently of me probably
why your diagnostics flagged it
mm-hmm okay but no data will leak out of
it through the personal link
your ride's secure fine i trust you
won't [ __ ] anything up
okay here goes nothing
you see that pile of junk fire a short
burst into it
i'll take care of the calibration
next target single shot
okay just one more longer round
great we're done i think and that wasn't
so bad was it
calibration's fine but your soft could
really use an update
scanner controllers all a couple of
generations back at least
it's better tech in the bargain bin at a
kabuki flea market
i can help you with that you know yes
sure the most important thing is that it
works now
so where's this power station you will
see in a moment
i know a spot we'll have a decent view
from there
i just want to be sure the area is clear
sabotage your corvo power station
jump a corporate transport kidnap a
corporate
suit there's a plug for the word
corporal or do you have a point
know what you're starting to remind me
of me
50 years back minus the charisma
an impressive [ __ ] hmm
maybe we can just get along
could be something to that i suppose
what happened to us it must have had
some effect
you're more like me than you think
you'll see
but it goes both ways maybe you're
becoming more like me
nah no way
all looks clear the area looks deserted
i see no patrols
the huge thing is the collection unit
and see the antennas
each antenna collects microwave energy
from satellites in orbit
that's then converted into electric
power
antennas running ways down the
interstate we set off a chain reaction
that starts in the collection unit
then each antenna will emit a massive
emp burst while
our av flies right into our net we just
have to send out the pulse at the right
moment
let's go get her when we arrive at the
station you overload the systems
i'll set up a bypass link for the
detonator
why don't i start with the transformers
make mayhem in the relative voltages
rest should move faster after that not a
bad idea
that's just yeah yeah i know the
converters but they shouldn't be a
problem
i'll just crank everything up past max
seems we think alike
so what now we wait we should time our
arrival to the av flight
got it
good time to roll
done anything like this before downing
an av
by myself no why do you ask
power station emp the systems
networks came up with a really solid
plan
thank you how you approach things that's
the trick
minus the aaa wait what now assessment
assembly action whatever your task
you do three things start by assessing
what you already have
and what you'll face the problem then
you plan with those variables in mind
take what you have get what you need
assemble things people
finally you take action simple got one
word for you
t-shirts aaa it's all you need to lead
the good life
that end the occasional cold beer
your method aaa that all you
not at all i learned it from the alta
caldos mention scorpion
they were trained in something like it
during the war then they made it their
own
it's come in handy i can't deny and it
will again now
what if uh something goes ass up
well then your ass had better improvise
did you really think i'd just give you a
foolproof secret to success
gotta say almost had me believing just
that
you're too much sometimes be
okay we'll be there in a moment one last
time
we drive in [ __ ] up the system and get
the hell out of there
hold on tight this could get a little
bumpy
get ready okay
i'm ready
i'll deal with it still quick before
they hit
we hurry
find the controls i'll connect the
detonator quick feed
ah [ __ ]
come on ah
[ __ ] i think we might have overdone it
pan am
good
[Music]
do you see that all lit up and blinking
like a christmas oh you wanted 11
you got to live yeah let's get out of
here before it lights us up too
v get the [ __ ] out before something
happens to the chance of the tip
you know i was just about to set up a
picnic maybe layout work
watch out the next one might johnny
johnny
[ __ ] hell okay
i'm fine it's it's okay
just it's okay i'm fine yeah
just dealt to the [ __ ] out
not the cleanest job perhaps but it
still went well what about the detonator
is it working yes it's working and i
don't even see a drop in the signal
strength
we just need to drive far away enough to
keep the pulse from blasting us too
the cliff there we'll set up it should
give us a good view of the antennas
and then we wait okay
here always wanted to push the big red
button on something like this
how do we know when don't worry i'll
have eyes on it
you just wait for my signal then set off
that pulse
they won't know what hit them
and by the way what we are about to
knock a multi-million euro dollar kang
tao asset clean out of the sky
how does that make you feel
blessed and [ __ ] exactly what the doc
ordered and that's exactly what i like
to hear
just noticed what it's quiet
the home of the city people's voices the
it's all gone wind just intensifies it
think i forgot quiet exists
though maybe not the smells i mean the
coyotes
rather hard to miss i thought that was
just the air freshener in your thornton
ha-ha screw you you'd do better to focus
on the av
keep your eyes open
it's there coming from pacifica all
right
get ready one more second one more
now boom there she is
[ __ ] what's happening great just great
[ __ ] hell bullseye
pan am the engines are still running
[ __ ] they're getting away they're going
nowhere
we gotta go after it give me a moment
pan am what are you doing
that's how you do it it's losing
altitude
we got the bastard let's go
no way it stays in the air after a blast
like that land
or crash